within the last hour or so we've learned
that the glastonbury festival has been
cancelled for the second year in a row
because of the coronavirus pandemic it
would have been
the 50th anniversary of glastonbury
skies entertainment reporter bethany
mannell joins us now
bethany it's a bitter blow this
absolutely it seems somewhat inevitable
though i mean obviously this is an
annual pilgrimage for hundreds and
thousands of music lovers who want to go
along
but this is a case of deja vu obviously
last year we were
breaking similar news after michael and
emily evis the organizers of the
festival
had to cancel the 50th anniversary
celebration which was a really big deal
that had of course been due to go ahead
last summer in 2020
now we're in 2021 and we're getting the
same
news again um emily evis
and michael uh who run worthy farm
they've actually uh put out a statement
on their official webpage
and i can read it to you now it says in
spite of our efforts to move heaven and
earth
it's become clear that we simply will
not be able to make the festival happen
this year
we're so sorry to let you all down as
with last year we would like to offer
those who secured a ticket in october
2019 the opportunity to roll their
50-pound deposit over to next year
and guarantee you the chance to buy a
ticket for glastonbury 2022
obviously at the moment 2022 seems
a heck of a way off doesn't it really um
but the fact is that this year had been
completely sold out because
so many people back in 2020
had made that decision to keep hold of
their tickets they simply didn't want to
give them back because they're just like
gold dust and and you've really got to
remember that
that this is really more than just
music lovers being disappointed they
can't go to their their favorite gig
and the live music industry is is worth
50 billion alone so this kind of loss
is is a massive blow to the industry and
obviously at a time like this
when when it's suffering so badly due to
coronavirus
this is that this is a real blow for
music lovers across the country